[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
私は今名古屋大学のホームページで
メダイウォッチというコラムを書いています
ホームページにはこんなふうに紹介されています
新聞社で長年各報道に携わってきたてアナル人が
大学の中を歩きながら
大学の今を
理由な立場で綴っていきます
別の言い方をすれば
外の目で大学を見て発信するということです
もちろん
私が何を買っかどう書くかということについて大学は一切口を挟まないということに
なっています
こんな風にジャーナル人が大学の中に入って
大学のことを継続的に書いていく
こういう試みは全国の大学でも例がないということです
私は記者時代
東京大阪
さらに
科学担当の特派員としてアメリカのはシートにも三年
駐在しました
その時には
nasa のロケットの打ち上げの取材などにも出かけてきました
そして3年前に
名古屋大学にまいりました
以来
いわば名古屋大学9剤という形になっています
そして
その結果
これまで知らなかった大学の姿が見えてきました
一言で言えば
驚きの連続です
こんなことがあったんだ
そしてもひとつ
そうした大学の姿は
ほとんど外には見えていない
伝わっていない
ということもを感じています
では具体的にどんなことを書いているんでしょうか
まず
私が面白いと思ったこと
伝えたいと思ったことです
でさらに
元新聞記者としての私は
もう一つの機銃を設けています
新聞やテレビの報道には全国ニュースとローカルニュースがありますが
この区分でいけば
全国ニュースを書くということです
つまり全国から見ても面白い
えって思ってもらえる
ということです
こんなことを言うと
書くことがなくなっちゃうんじゃないのとか心配して下さる方がおられるかもしれませ
ん
でもその心配はご無用です私はこれまで各材料に困ったということはありません
名古屋大学は
皆さんが想像する以上に
ネタの宝庫なんです
例えば
it bm という研究所がありますちょうどこの建物の隣にあります
愛はいいし中途研究所体はトランスフォーマティブ世界を変える
b はバイオ生命 m は
モレキュール同意し
つまり生命現象に関わる
パック的な分子を開発してそれによって世界を書いていこうというわけです
しかしそれにしても研究所の名前に世界を変える
これはなかなかすごいことではないでしょうか
あまり聞いたことがないような規模します
さすがに日本語で世界を変える研究所と言ってしまうのは気恥ずかしいということで
トランスフォーマティ部と言うか高田を使っていますけれども
大きな志が分かります
実際ここの研究所からは次々
新しい研究成果が出て国内だけでなく国際的にも注目される
研究所になっています
その背景として
私は
あることで注目しましたそれはこの研究所のいわば誕生の秘密です
実は
この研究所は文部科学省のプログラムに応募して2回落ちている
色なんです
予算規模も大きいので大変な難関でした
3回目再々挑戦するにあたって
若い人たちにすべてを任せるという道を選び
そしてそれが見事に実を結びました
確かにに路などと言われるとちょっと格好悪いです
しかしその結果
思い切って
若い人にすべてを任せる
そこに
名古屋大学だし佐賀そしてや護衛大学の若さ強さが表れていると私は思いました
でその結果がこの名前に
若い情熱がほとばしる研究所の誕生につながりました
でここでは
生物学者と理由学者がこれまでにない
協力体制を作り上げました
で例えばそのを急い可能
例です
けれども
アフリカで作物をからしている
悪魔の脱走と呼ばれる寄生植物
1ライガーというのが大変大きな問題になっていますがその悪魔をやっつける
ぶー4を
開発しました
試験はこれからですがうまくいけば
アフリカの食糧問題の解決に大きく
9できるのではないかと期待されています
名古屋大学からノーベル賞受賞者が6人
相次いで出たということは皆さんよくご存知だと思いますが
その背景にも
坂田スクール平田スクールと呼ばれて優れた
ペグ厩舎の下で若い研究者たちが思う存分に力を発揮するそんな環境がありました
そんなことも思い出しました
背景を知るといろいろ興味も湧いてくると思います
一方
ここにしかないというものもあります
例えば
この建物
災害を防ぐの腕はなく減らす
減災という言葉は今でこそおなじみですが個々の研究者たちがいち早く
この言葉を使い始め
この建物にも
現在丸という名前をつけました
この建物がユニークなのは
5階建てのこの建物全体を
いつでも
地震のときだけではなくいつでも震度3で揺らすことができるということなんだよ
南海トラフ地震が迫ると言われている中で
教育と研究その工場は待ったなしでも課題だからです
一方で
ここを防災とはちょっと離れて教育の目的で使おうという先生もいます
例えば神道という基本的な重要だ
現象があります
それを実地でここで体験して学生はその後で理論を学ぶ
教室が揺れるわけですからまあ居眠りをしているわけにもいかない
位相学習効果が上がるということのようです
ユニークだたっ施設にはいろいろな使い方があるものだと思わされます
邦楽の分野では
アジア諸国を対象に法律づくりを様々な形で支援するという活動も30年
近く続けられてきました
そうした活動の中で私が感心した事の一つに現地の大学生に日本語で日本の法律を
教えるというものがあります
4年間であいうようから初めて
日本国憲法刑法民法まで学生は本当に大変です
しかし
翻訳リー頼ることなく日本の法律を
2区
学び考え理解することができます
同時に法律を学ぶという目的がはっきりしているので日本語の上達も早いということ
です
学生たちは日常的にできるだけ日本語を使おうということを心がけているそうで
例えば
先生この方を私に対応してくださいと言った
微笑ましい会話が交わされているということもベンチで行った時に聞きました
他に様々なことを書いていますが最近書いたものでは
今秋に染めのタッチダウンに挑む
小惑星探査機はやぶさつ
それから様々な用途が広がって注目されている3 d プリンター
そういったものについて書きましたいっ
これらが名古屋大学とどんな関係があるんだろうと思われた方はぜひホームページを
のぞいてみてください
意外なつながりに驚かれるかもしれません
こんな風に
名越大学等したここにしかないことその背景をいろいろ書いてきたんですが
1残念なことはこうしたことが学内でも必ずしもよく知られている
というわけではないことです
名古屋大学出版会という学術出版の世界では非常によく知られた優れた出版界があり
ますがそこの名編集長と話していたときに彼がこんなことを言っていました
先生たちはちょっと専門が違うとまるで違う星から来た異星人のように言葉も通じない
ことがある
せっかくこの総合大学にいながら
もったいないことですよね
確かに大学は一つの小宇宙のようなものかもしれません
学部ガーリー研究所があり様々な活動人をしている人たちがいる
そこで星々が
キラキラ輝いている
水性や姿勢が表れることもある
そんなそう小宇宙いいながらお互いに知らない言葉の通じないとしたらやはり何とも
残念
もったいないことだと皆さんも生まれるのではないでしょうか
私自身
実は苦い経験があります
記者になっていっ
私が卒業した大学に取材に行きました
ん
すると面白いことがたくさんあります
これが私が4年間過ごした大学なんだろうかと思ったほどでした
なぜもっと色々なところを見ておかなかったんだろう
訪ねておかなかったんだろうと思いましたがもう後の祭り
今私がなご依頼がこうある決まっているのは私なりのリベンジなのかもしれません
最後に
大きな科学的発見などの際によく引用される
フランスの科学者パスツールの言葉を引用したいと思います
ジャンスペイバー2たプリペアド mine
ちゃんスコーンは準備されたものに訪れる
大切なのは準備するということで
いろいろなことを知っておくこと
自分の頭で考えること
考え続けること
いろいろな準備があります
大学はマザーに準備するのに学校の場所ではないでしょうか
あなたが
この小宇宙の住人なら
いつでもどこでも
自由にたずに歩ける特権があります
しかし
この焼酎は
そこに住む人たちのだけのものでは決してありません
開かれています
私が
名越大学に来て驚いたことの一つにここには
訪問というものがないということがありまん
文字通り開かれています
著名な建築家の槇文彦さんはそんな名古屋大学のために
門をイメージしてこの建物を設計しました
名古屋大学のシンボルと枝行動デー
焼酎があなたを待っています
さあこのもうをくぐりましょう
もっと知りましょう
知れば
さらに
知りたくなる
そこから新しい世界が広がってくる
そしていつか
チャンスがやってくる
きゃんぱすわー
本当に驚きに満ちて今どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]